[Rires]
allez-y vous
écoutes rappelez-vous 1936 le Front
populaire les grèves mais surtout les
premiers congés
payés
[Musique]
hiver 73 champini sur marne beaucoup des
premiers vacanciers de 36 sont
aujourd'hui à la retraite parmi eux
Monsieur et Madame faré 75 et 73 ans ça
vous fait pas peur un petit peu madame
far de prendre l'avion c'estàdire que je
sera peut-être un petit
émotionné mais autrement je suis très
heureuse quand même de de le prendre et
pouvoir dire je vais mourir et j'ai pris
le baptême de l'air et c'est pas un
petit peu difficile pour de retraiter
sur le plan financier de partir 3
semaines oh mais que voulez-vous bien
sûr il y a combien de temps qu'on pas
pris de vacances ça fait au moins 3 ans
je crois
oui 3 ans oui qu'est-ce que vous en
attendez de ce
voyage d'abord une grande détente et ça
nous changera un petit peu de la vie
dans l'appartement où on s'ennuie
[Musique]
quelquefois départ à destination de
Palma
535 embarquement immédiat porte numéro
44 destination Palma des majorques
capitale du Nil au tourisme de masse
lieu de prédilection pour un grand
nombre de Français caractéristique de la
capitale
ignore la saison creuse et accueille des
touristes toute l'année à 30 km de Palma
un petit port tranquille Puerto solaire
une station touristique certes mais qui
a su conserver un caractère décontracté
familial depuis 3 ans déjà en hiver les
vacanciers du 3è âge les retraités
peuvent y séjourner à des conditions
particulièrement intéressantes certains
y restent 3 semaines d'autres de plus en
plus nombreux 2 mois au total cet hiver
près de d'entre S sont
retrouvés mon FO me taquine pas mon
estomac est
tranquille je me sens l'Est comme si
j'avais 20
ans ici ça me plaît parce que c'est du
vrai repos j'ai pas de cuisine à faire
pas de ménage pas de cour je suis de
vacances je crois qu'on peut pas trouver
beaucoup mieux je suis heureux comme
j'ai jamais été encore jusqu'à présent
et pourtant j'ai passé des vacances dans
beaucoup d'endroits mais pas comme
[Musique]
ici j'ai 73 ans et je suis venu au
bénéfice du 3è âge naturellement je suis
retraité j'ai des petits moyens quoi on
les utilise au mieux mais je suis très
satisfait moi qui étais un gros mangeur
et bien j'ai subi j'ai subi c'est le cas
de le dire mais avec presque amour d'ce
et org le bénéfice du régime joet je
sais bien chter à la corde
maintenant
la nourriture c'est pas de la nourriture
française faut pas comparer la
nourriture espagnole avec la nourriture
française ça ne se compare
[Musique]
pas c'est pas la nourriture française
mais ENF ce n'est pas mal l'eau est
bonne très bonne
est bien chauffé on est très
bien
[Musique]
j'ai fait une veste veste blanche parce
que j'avais pas prévu qu'il fer si beau
ça et il me manque une veste blanche la
nourriture ça nous convient parce que
c'est pas très salé alors c'est
bien qu'on a connu c'est
[Musique]
parfait repte ce
soir
impression à toi vas-y oh les
impressions écoutez un très joli
panorama mais par exemple à l'El où nous
sommes un Porteau solaire pour les pour
les personnes âgé c'est les marches qui
sont bien ennuyeuses il faudrait même au
moins qu'il y ait une barre dans le
milieu et moins de de March usagé
surtout pour des personnes du Moyen-Âge
qu'est-ce qui manque surtout il faut
laverver quoi c'est la nourriture vous
n'avez pas apprécié la nourriture non du
tout du tout non
comme moi je suis un peu cuisinier hein
et je cuisine pas mal sû et ben la
nourriture ça va pas ça va pas non non
la touriture c'est vraiment zéro
d'ailleurs vous savez comme je vous dis
quand vous avez quand vous voyez un chef
cuisinier qui sort d' d'être d'être
plongeur dans un autre restaurant et
puis qui met chef cuisine là-haut alors
il pas d'en dire
davantage pour permettre à ces hôtels
fermés de demeurer ouverts un homme
Francesco Vence a pensé à une clientèle
jusqu'àors inexploitée celle du 3è âge
il a obtenu le concours d'organisation
de loisirs et celui des hôteliers de la
station maintenant de toute part
arrivrive par avion des retraités de
tous
âes vous avez des oranges comme chign ah
non il y a pas d' ah c'est les fris ah
les fraises alors ça les fraises il y en
a les fraises il y a combien d'hôtel
ouvert en ce moment à ce moment-ci il y
en a
neuf avec une capacité totale environ de
1200 l c'est une opération rentable pour
les hôteliers bah écoutez euh on sait
que c'est qui est rentable c'est c'est
toujours rentable sinon il le ferait
pas c'est vrai oui on est quand
même autre bénéficiaire de l'opération
vacances 3e âge les commerçants bien sûr
vous êtes le propriétaire de ce magasin
de souvenirs oui monsieur oui qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de cet afflu de touriste
ici en fait pour maork pour tout
l'Espagne c'est une grande chose c'est
vrai c'est c'est ce que le pense surtout
tous les commerçants voyezvous il y a eu
un phénomène ici c'est qu'avant tout
était fermé oui avant oui fait déjà de
enfit pas 2 ans mais TR ou 4 années que
c'était déjà avant fermé partout oui
votre magasin était fermé à cette époque
oui oui parce que en fait dans l'hiver
oui surtout les 4 mois d'hiver parce
qu'il y avait pas de
pas de monde en fait on doit fermer on a
rien à faire sais pas
plus Jol dans le
[Rires]
tunnelzy allez-y vous
écoute des
ref
[Applaudissements]
un séjour pour 3 semaines en pension
complète coûte 680 francs 25 francs par
jour voyage compris seule surprise le
vin est gratuit mais il faut payer
l'eau vous êtes maintenant des habitués
des balayards il y a longtempsous somes
des habitués des balayards il y a
combien de temps vous venez ici depuis 4
ans 4 hivers passé ici et vous êtes
arrivé quand le 2 janvier vous restez
jusqu'à quand jusqu'au 11 avril
c'estàdire long comme s jour très
longtemps très bon hiver nous attendons
qu'il fasse meilleur pour retourner dans
le Nord est-ce que sur le plan financier
ça pose pas de gros problème ça ne pose
pas de gros problème si on peut payer
d'avance parce qu'onaccepte pas de payer
à termch mais ça vous coûte quand même
beaucoup plus cher que si vous étiez
resté dans la banliue Lilloise non
précisément non parce que chez vous si
vous voulez avoir un petit peu de
confort il faut le payer et ici les
hôtels font des prixs très intéressant
quand c'est un long séjour pour
personnes
âgées on vient de rencontrer au le là
qui nous a fait
dé nous avons 20 ans voilà on a pas tout
les jours 20 ans bien fa bien s'user
mais c'est on passe de B est a longtemps
que vous êtes ici oui 5 semaines ça vous
plaît oui ça fait déjà de fois que je
viens'est que vousvez fait de spécial
pendant votre séjour ici ah ben nous
avons fait de des excursions nous sommes
amusés entre nous et qu'est-ce qui vous
attire ici qu'est-ce qui vous fait
revenir chaque année le climat la vue le
paysage le les distractions distraction
et puis on est bien on essaie de faire
ce qui est pas fait habituellement dans
un dans les voyages organisés c'est des
promen à pied des to pétang de belotes
et C et même des petites pièces de
théâtre ils sont arrivés à un certain
âge est-ce qu'il n'y a pas une
difficulté de rapport entre vous et eux
au début sûrement oui puisquils vont
plus facilement vers une Hautesse qui
est une
demoiselle et j'ai peut-être un aspect
réveratif mais après au bout de quelques
mots gentils ils viennent tout de suite
je suis le Petitfils je suis la mère je
suis
le le fils
mêmeon ceux qui ne peuvent pas marcher
au restaurant où on vient de passer le
belavista et après avec ceux qui peuvent
marcher on monte le long du
T à la Guer 70
il est bien fu
celui-là allez faut pas t culer allez
arrive je vais t'emmener
[Musique]
tiens étonnant enthousiasme de ces gens
qui ont tous au moins 60 ans beaucoup
plus bien souvent et qui pourtant n'ont
pas peur de dire leur âge ils sont
heureux de parcourir les sentiers de
lîle même s'il faut faire plusieurs
kilomètres pour y arriver de bavarder
sur la plage ou de regarder partir les
bateaux
il se plaignent rarement et remercient
toujours beaucoup luttent ensemble
contre la solitude c'est l'évasion
totale le
[Musique]
dépaysement il y a une soirée de
déguisement prévu est-ce que vous allez
y aller
ben pour le déguisement peut-être que
nous allons hésiter quand même mais
enfin pour y aller ça nous y serons
certainement ça vous change de champign
ah oui oh là là beaucoup je passenseraai
bien de TR mois ici et vous comptez
revenir ah oui certainement
oui
oui la soirée flamenco est
traditionnelle à Puerto solaire elle
signifie que le départ est proche il va
falloir reprendre l'avion rentrer cet
hiver ils étaient 5000 l'hiver prochain
grâce à de nouveaux charterurs ils
seront peut-être 6000 ainsi des
retraités de plus en plus nombreux
pourront aller passer l'hiver au bord de
la Méditerranée pour eux il y a quelque
chose peut-être de plus précieux que le
voyage l'évasion la fin d'une solitude
des souvenirs qu'on est graraine des
amitiés qui se créent et pourquoi pas
une espérance il y a eu cette année
parmi ces retraités du 3è âge un mariage
à poirteau solaire lui avait 76 ans elle
72 pour le soleil tout est
possible on se retrouve demain matin
comme d'habitude pour la gymnastique à
9h30
1 2 au maximum on va croiser deux fois
devant tris devant 1 2 3 4 1 2 3
[Musique]
4 il m les bagages jeis Jean-François on
met les bagages là il mettre dans le au
revoir je-fançois et merciz al au revoir
revoir
peuttre demain matin
Radi ça y est au revoir jean-fançois
merci c'est vousz
revoirour les beau jours les beau
joursciour tu
[Musique]
veux